انقل لكم هذا العاجل مسؤول رفيع في
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه يقول لا علاقه لنا
بالهجوم الذي استهدف الكرملين اذا نفي من
كييف عن مسؤوليتها عن هذا الهجوم كيف يمكن
ان تتفاعل موسكو مع هذا النفي
كيف ايضا نفت قشفه
الجسر في شبه جزيره القرم والذي ادى الى
قتله مدنيين كان في اجازه اذا كيف بالطبع
لن تتحمل المسؤوليه رسميا ولن تعلن عن
مسؤوليته الرسميه ولكن
الروسي سوف تقوم بعمليه تحقيق ولكن اذا ما
كان هناك محاوله من اوكرانيا
فان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بغض النظر سواء
كانوا وزراء او رؤساء وزراء او ايا كان
سوف يكونون هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
ولكن
ما هي مصلحه اوكرانيا الاوكرانيون ينفون
الان ولكن ما مصلحتهم في ان يقوموا
باستهداف الكريملون على هذا النحو ثم تكون
هناك تداعيات كبيره
يعني دائما في اي عمل يقال من المستفيد
فما الفائده التي ستجنيها اوكرانيا اصلا
اوكرانيا نفت هذا لان هذا لن يجد تعاطفا
في واشنطن وبروكسل
فالحلفاء الغربيون لاوكرانيا لن يوافقوا
بان هذا التحرك كان حصيفا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا تعتبر هذا نشرا رمزيا اي دوله
صغيره اوكرانيا يمكن لها ان تستهدف الرئيس
الروسي وهم يعتقدون بالتالي بان هذا سوف
يرفع معنويات جنودهم في وجه
العمليه التي ستقوم بها اوكرانيا عمليه
وهجوم مضاد ولكن النتائج والتدايت على
اوكرانيا يمكن وعلى الارجح سوف تكون وحشيه
وق